[Music]
I love science
can you even imagine we back in the past
where we thought that spots were caused
by petty gods fighting on top of the
mountain and yeah I like a good story
but eventually it's gonna bar me if it
doesn't have that truth that
incontrovertible testable repeatable
poor I love science
four thousand years old
to argue is
long sigh times people ask me of all of
the centuries which I'd pick to live
life in well that's pretty easy right
now
think objectively if you like hot
running water and memory foam beds and
TV shows and cell phones and not being
telling you love science
science will be man
supersonic jets
[Music]
I love science
the truth is
there's nothing here to monarchy
[Music]
that is the first track on my new album
incongruent with Hank green and the
perfect strangers incongruent now has an
official release date that date May 7th
that's when it will be available on
iTunes it will be shipping out of the
dftba warehouse a little bit before that
all of those things shipping out if you
preorder the album will be signed and
you will also get an email with download
links so that you could download the
mp3s because I know not everybody has a
CD drive in their computer anymore and
we are gone on tour after VidCon Los
Angeles San Francisco Portland Seattle
Boise Denver Salt Lake City possibly
Eugene there's a link in the description
if you want to get tickets for some
peculiar reasons it is extra important
that we sell tickets in Seattle Salt
Lake in Denver quickly basically the
people booking the shows don't believe
us because we've never toured before and
we need to show them that we could sell
tickets so that will be nice to us and
this is not just me on this tour it is
also Rob Scallon it is also Andrew Huang
it is also Driftless Pony Club the band
of wheezy waiter and it is also Harry
and the Potters it's going to be a lot
of fun I'm excited about it all the
shows are all ages and all the tickets
are under $20 the price is very I love
science John I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]